hey [ __ ] other two boys psycho [ __ ]
rebel and here we are
let's see what's going on in this [ __ ]
huh oh hey there you are what's crackin
so we all good hell yeah we all good we
did yeah you [ __ ] a right we did yeah
there's a shot right that Lester's
offloading the gems he knows a guy it's
50 cents on the dollar oh now we might
actually have a little spending money
left after we pay off that psychotic
Mexican [ __ ] Oh cheers so that's
dead right now so the whole job
everything about it anyone who knows
your file what is wrong with you Davey
long time no see and what about Trevor
if that fruitcake realizes no no finds
out you're alive you r do and II [ __ ]
don't worry about Trevor Trevor is dead
gotta be sighs I they have nothing to do
with whatever the hell it is you're
talking about oh really the criminals
are believed to escape with millions of
dollars with you hey our story had a
lucky escape from the thieves lens
straight into I was doing my job and I
say this guy hey you got to move these
bikes I don't know anything about that
this other guy runners on the stop at
gender said something last time to get
back to the things every day make sure
this is wonderful pretty scary back to
you in the studio
you want to get rid now sugar Trevor
baby you want it now Sulochana don't do
it Trevor you be with my girl again I'm
speaking with you [ __ ] I'll do it
Johnny I told him forever I told him we
all get high we all get high but that
don't make it right knee leaving
crystals gotta see but right there
nothing right now what you done with me
ranjan you leave it hey leavin nothin
Trevor I'm talking to you [ __ ]
are you what are you saying [ __ ] my
girl man it's wrong oh I gotta [ __ ]
someone you want me to [ __ ] you instead
is that the problem here take off your
pants yeah biiitch [ __ ] do you think
this is funny what zoopla I told him to
leave it Trevor I told him leave it
leave it shut up Ron I'm about the [ __ ]
me a Methody night cowboy get my boy
suck from his toothless gums [ __ ] you
Trevor oh I still love her all right
cowboy hey I know hey come on any
nothing biomass righteous I know Lester
I know cowboy it's okay it's okay baby
touch who the [ __ ] are you speaking to
who oh I'm talking to you huh you [ __ ]
hottie next time don't get in my [ __ ]
face I just saw [ __ ] ghost and I got
to hear your crap get up get up [ __ ] you
then wait Danny's dad Kenny says oh
that's Ally
na the wheels are in motion we got to
reach out to the rest of them that's
that [ __ ] asses take care where we go
it wait the ghost I saw his name is
Michael Townley sounds like he's living
in Los Angeles find them really my
taärgons Arabic I don't find them wait
you're just me not gonna have to come
see the bikers were in a hurry
but not that much of a hurry but if we
bury job
[Applause]
van KO he cannot imagine you think of
climbers and disrespect women kickers
back what I want you give it back and
out of your day we should tell her you
called her a fifth if you got a mother
and a cat record flood
step that farm on the right that's where
they're men today
hey you seen Ashley Johnny's looking for
well you know as a matter of fact I just
did just 10 minutes ago yeah I saw her
on the end of this penis here Johnny
ain't gonna be cool if you met them with
her again oh really well you don't think
so huh well why don't we just ask him
then huh hey hey cowboy you mind that I
[ __ ] your old lady sorry what would not
go no no no you don't mind oh because
you're a dead man and the only sentient
party all laugh this is a little bit of
brain bring the girl on the end of my
boat well thank you very much cowboy
[ __ ] oh I like it denial that is
first part of the greeting guys are
crazy now let's all hold it looks like
you got something you want to say huh
you got something you need to say this
better be [ __ ] oh where you guys
going up let's go ladies let's go later
alright follow the van back to the rest
of us and the lost MCR out of this
region for good kids back but I you drop
those white [ __ ] a what's up till that
time where are you gon [ __ ] [ __ ] Rock
now we're gonna get those who're limit
[Music]
take us back to the camp this area ain't
gonna have a biker problem much longer
the Vans gotta pack but the guys on
fight is Joe
you see the look on their faces sweet
scared of cake we didn't make sense to
harm as idiots you are yes you need
complete the choten gray hair I only
keep things in the back I don't mind
loose oh
that's a start laughs
alrighty Ruth now we just put on the
side you get to them I can't see it
taking out all the spices 60 cause I
mean still be some by that airstrip come
over so by that noctuidae their time
will soon be upon us what are we [ __ ]
now
if we go off the side on the left there
we should make it across
oh yeah good
good God we're all running for Dad
which of you we sell him
[Music]
gah fetch come on
you let him go on perfect cover I don't
want to hear another peep
beyond that there is oh yeah I could
lose them at all where we catch
so he showed up for couple brews
Oh
we're right on me prick
yeah rock solid oh look look hurry up
you better trouble they're stopping sit
back and watch the show you useless
prick
you got a highly explosive
oh gosh
I can't ever dad no one leaves without
my express permission
step right up step right up got got
[Applause]
finding me to go around no driving
privileges
now
now this is [ __ ] crazy I warned
Ronnie and I'll warn you to say
[Music]
step right up step right up
I got got
[Music]
[Applause]
this is [ __ ] it hey suddenly
everything
I organ donor
stop rat up
come on we're just got started yes that
says
better step in any time sucks now wait
what are you still doing here but you
said I said go find a [ __ ] ghost in
Los Santos all right you're looking for
motivation oh yeah pick me up some
sticky bomb I'll take a live near here
let's go see him it's one thing messing
with three thousand bucks huh yeah let
me a second man the ass catches just
been named the Illuminati as well and a
wacky found one of the lizard people I
got his Chinese contact me again he'll
buy all the mess missing from our
enterprise ain't just about mass must
guns to be a second control the gun so
we're taking them out there he is let's
wake them up what with the truck no come
on Ortega runs the hotel
come on yeah
come on here for daddy do it for daddy
what the [ __ ] level this is the [ __ ] my
soggy friend ok goo or out of business
the lost MC are out of business the guns
and crank in this area go through Trevor
Phillips enterprise or they ain't going
saying something don't make it true we
was always cool you've over weeks you're
just one man you can't hold the whole of
the Alamo see you get the picture I
thought you was crazy man not stupid you
sure you want to do this I'll go away
man but my people I think he gets it doc
becca's is an international enterprise I
don't like the way he's looking at me
they didn't agree like to act of it he's
looking at me the shot goal is ain't
gonna be happy think about it I always
let you operate I didn't have to you
sure you want to do this hey Joe is cool
I think he gets it I thought you were
crazy man I stupid I don't like the way
he's looking at me I'll go away man for
my people he's looking at me dr.
this is the International exercise think
about it Oh Oh Phil you sure me Dad gun
you like that [ __ ] cousin funny more
quick
this is an unprecedented turn of the
bank I always said I was going to take
over
people fail x sub winners three days
into a social party calling me a
bullshitter friends clearly not no way
you're a man of your word and evidence
like said event if I say something is
going to happen it's going to maybe not
today or tomorrow it is take a homemade
opportune under good yes if I say I'm
[ __ ] dead then [ __ ] dead i am i'm
not gonna raise my ball to get on a
beach 10-year times and I'll as well is
this amounts of gold Michael Wacha
dollar yes it is who you told me about
you drove running fight and who is
everyone Brad the other one locked up in
a federal penitentiary when he finds out
my sister fight
yeah what is the castle
you what happened I wouldn't be
bemoaning these last ten years get out
of the car Ron any time to spank rod
Thank at thank Jeff replaces [ __ ] off
good cat thanks for watching betcha
thank you